good afternoon and thank you all for
coming to today's meeting of the noam
chomsky reading group we are a book club
who meet monthly here at vertigo books
to in order to discuss the life and
political work of Noam Chomsky vertigo
Books is located at 13:37 Connecticut
Avenue Northwest in Washington DC the
phone number is two zero two four two
nine nine two seven two please call the
store for further information about our
forthcoming events all of our events are
free and open to the public today we're
honored and pleased to have with us
professor Robert Barsky professor of
English at the University of Western
Ontario in Canada Robert is the author
of introduction to literary theory
constructing a productive other
discourse theory and the convention
refugee hearing co-editor with Michael
hull Quist of baktun and other Nastase
cently of Noam Chomsky a life in descent
a political biography just published by
MIT press we are very glad to have
robert with us today to this to share
with us the fruits of his research in
into the the intellectual origins and
background of Noam Chomsky's political
work thank you Robert for coming the the
format today will be it will consist of
a brief initial presentation by Robert
followed by our usual informal
discussion and there's free coffee and
cookies here for anybody interested
thank you
thank you mark thank you very very much
for having me it's a pleasure and an
honor to be with you amongst people who
know his work and the work of Noam
Chomsky so well and who have been
debating it for so long in a sense my
contribution and my interests are
represented a small area of Chomsky's
work I have been over the last years
concerned with the mill years
particularly the early mill years that
were formative for Chomsky in terms of
hit both his politics and his
linguistics in that sense
Noam Chomsky 'life of descent speaks
very much to the early these early mill
years and with a sense that I have that
so much of what Chomsky is referring to
from these many years I'll talk about a
couple of them remain useful for an
understanding of contemporary society so
the two groups are the two individuals
that I'd like to refer to to to whom I
will refer today are two of the groups
that are two individuals I take to be
extremely important in terms of these
early male viewers Selig Harris and
Rudolf rocker so let me read this and
then we shall have a talk about their
their continued implications one of the
principal claims that I make in Noam
Chomsky 'life of descent is it a whole
corpus of knowledge that's useful for
discussions about and evaluations of
contemporary society are unknown to the
majority if not the vast majority of
society there may very well be reasons
for this including conscious attempts on
the part of people's variously empowered
to harp on weak alternatives to the
present day capitalist societies in
order to avoid the serious issues raised
by more
valuable criticisms and proposals it
seems likely therefore that those who
uphold the status quo find
unquestionable legitimation when they
compare their actions to the likes of
dictators and so forth it was of course
particularly fortuitous that Lenin and
Stalin and the whole Bolshevik Party
came to bear the label of Marxist or
communist despite the fact that their
actions bore virtually no resemblance to
either Marxism or communism as
envisioned by Marx and various
supporters of communism the stronger
versions of either Marxism or communism
such as ant the anti-bolshevik variety
or the council communists are seldom if
ever discussed in the contemporary world
another contention that I'd like to put
forth today is that Noam Chomsky's
political and to some degree his
linguistic and philosophical works as
well
Oh a significant debt to what
Chomsky calls classical liberals and
also to anarchists socialists and
anti-bolshevik Marxists and indeed that
his work serves as a valuable gateway
into the analyses provided there thereby
a whole series of figures can be
discussed in this regard from panikkar
to Kropotkin from matt from paul mattock
to godwyn but the figure the figures I'd
like to recall today are as I mentioned
Rudolf rocker in particular from his
monumental tome nationalism and culture
and zellig harris and here with regards
to his equally monumental tome which is
due to be released any time now called
the transformation of capitalist society
that was published by Roman Middlefield
let me begin with the Harris book the
question that underwrites this
fascinating study is how in a period of
firmly entrenched capitalism which is
intrinsically exclusionary but
remarkably a debt adapted to the
pressures of cyclical downturns and of
course firmly protected by ruling class
interests can we hope for a
transformation of capitalist society
Harris's approach in foreign by works by
figures such as Karl Korzh Karl Marx
Paul Maddock Anton pan okok and by
movements such as the maunder gone group
accounts with communists he would seem
points to a non political non-violent
potential that might grow out of
existing and possibly increasing
tendencies within contemporary
capitalism itself this movement is
towards accelerating the establishment
of what is called Aesop's that is
employees share ownership plans and more
generally a gradual growth of employee
ownership and control allow me to
emphasize here the non-violent and
almost spontaneous nature of this
transformation that Harris is referring
to as one way of distinguishing it from
say a state socialist project which
involves the kind of state direction if
not oppression upheld by the figures
about whom we know too much or not
enough Lenin Stalin Mao Mao and so forth
according to Harris in this book a
transformation of capitalist society is
necessary for several reasons first
quote the large and getting larger
unemployed and impoverished segment of
the population is excluded from the
benefits of capitalist production and
society end quote
second capitalism necessarily requires
profit making and profit maximizing for
quote an ever-expanding domain of
operation an expansion that cannot be
maintained forever and third says Harris
the earth's resources are undergoing
destruction
at an alarming rate this transformation
of crying Tijeras could occur because
cyclical economic downturn downturns
that occur regularly in contemporary
society and the inherent unprofitability
of certain sectors of the economy leave
open spaces for enhanced employee
participation so Harris's book looks
forward quote to a time when the decline
of capitalist production in various
countries economic sectors and companies
leaves workers without job prospects and
sectors of production inadequately
covered for the needs of the population
in Harris's view these circumstances are
appropriate for a situation whereby
employees could be quote included in
sharing control and then by virtue of
the changed attitudes of workers and
their newfound understanding of the
socio-economic situation these same
workers could develop new attitudes thus
paving the way for a more humane and
equitable society okay this is basically
what Harris discusses in this book
Chomsky does not share Harris's optimism
about e-stops Aesop's and Chomsky's view
often work for a very short period of
time and then once a company becomes
profitable again it is either sold to a
normal corporation or dissolved with the
employees taking the windfall further
the idea that this experience of
cooperating in a commonly owned
enterprise could change attitudes is for
Chomsky perhaps the somewhat unduly
optimistic and is not necessarily borne
out by the experiences that we've had
with existing you sobs nevertheless I
think the one can easily detect
similarities between this text at least
in terms of fundamental values and
approach and with many texts and with
the fundamental values and approach of
Noam Chomsky the second figure I'd like
to recall is Rudolf rocker when we look
to the major hypotheses proposed in
Rockers work some I think critically
important similarities emerge an
interesting case in point is rockers
view of liberalism as described in
nationalism
culture we're now I think probably
familiar with Chomsky's frequent
references to the writing of Humboldt or
Lakhan and his frequently repeated
statement that there exists a kind of
red thread linking what he calls
classical liberalism right which is what
Rochard calls liberalism to certain
strains of anarchism this link says
Chomsky was suggested to him early on in
the course of his reading works by
rocker to put it simply rockers shared
with upholders of liberalism a belief
that quote the continuous guardianship
of the state has been just as
detrimental to the fruitful development
of all creative forces in society as the
guardianship of the church had been in
previous centuries absolute freedom from
all sources of oppression and power the
church in earlier states in the state
today is a constant theme in rockers
work because says rocker only in freedom
does their a rise in man the
consciousness of responsibility for his
acts and regard for the rights of others
only in freedom can their unfold in its
full strength that most precious of
social instincts man's sympathy for the
joys and sorrows of his fellow man and
the resultant impulse towards mutual aid
in which are rooted all of social ethics
and all ideas of social justice
notice that this implies the idea that
there exists in man a kind of innate
evil is just both thoroughly discounted
in Rockers work and I must say in in
Chomsky's as well that the state should
not interfere with the lives of
individuals is of course only half the
story as told by either rocker or
Chomsky the other half is the
exploration of individual and collective
potential through this freedom and
indeed one half can become a measurement
of the other as is illustrated and
rockers reference to what he calls the
ancient wisdom of Protagoras which he
uses to bolster his own support for
liberalism rocker finds in poor
tigresses doctrine an evaluation of the
social environment that is based upon an
assessment of quote whether it further
the natural development of the
individual or as a hindrance to his
personal freedom and independence its
conceptions of society are those of an
organic process resulting from man's
natural necessities and leading to free
associations which exists as long as
they fulfill their purpose and dissolve
again when this purpose has become
meaningless meaningless I think that
that's a really nice statement of the
kind of society that's envisioned both
by rocker and also by Chomsky
and also I think it is an important
makes an important link between
anarchism refusal of all forms of
authority and liberalism's belief at
least as this version of liberalism's
believed that quote government in
certain matters cannot be disposed with
this sounds of course a bit like a
contradiction until we note with rocker
that this form of liberalism upholds a
belief that the state quote had a right
to exist only as long as its
functionaries strove to protect the
personal safety of its citizens against
forcible attacks okay so what about a
Marxist state then we're talking about
the powers that a state can have to
protect the interests of an individual
why not turn towards a Marxist state
well Chomsky agrees with Rocker once
again on this point that anarchism as
they describe it is a much more serious
alternative to contemporary society than
most Marxism for reasons that were
described by rocker 60 almost 60 years
ago when he wrote that quote communism
is to be taken as merely a name for the
present Russian system of government
which is as far removed from the
original meaning of communism as a
socialism as a socialist system of
economic equality as is every other
system of government for instance in
nationalism and culture rocker notes
that a this famous dictatorship of the
proletarian one of the cornerstones of
course the manifesto and a legitimating
notion for the Bolshevik party at the
time remains a dictatorship a marxist
state says rocker is still a state and a
Bolshevik Party even in its earliest
manifestations
was always comprised of elites whose
interests were in maintaining a
totalitarian hold over the vast majority
of the citizens of the USSR but rockers
critique of Marx goes much further
sometimes right into the writings of
Marx himself citing Marx's famous line
that the philosophers have variously
interpreted the world and now it is time
to change it
rocker comments that Marx himself did
nothing during his whole life that
followed this precept except to
reinterpret the world and its history
says rocker Marx analyzed capitalistic
society in his way and showed a great
deal of intellect and enormous learning
in doing so but poodles creative power
was denied him he was and remained an
analyst a brilliant and learnand analyst
but nothing else this that Marx was but
a powerful theorist of capitalism is
something that has been noted frequently
in various mill years but rocker finds
and Marx has worked something that's
downright nefarious and limiting when he
suggests that quote marks and mesh the
minds of his followers in the fine
network of a cunning dialectic which
sees in history hardly anything but
economics and obstructs even every
deeper insight into the world of social
events this I think is a stunning
condemnation which is worth looking into
for the moment though it's worth
recalling Chomsky's own actors activism
and his own dislike for what he calls
Marx ology and the over theorization of
the social world at the heart of rockers
condemnation of Marx was as well a sense
that the transformation of capitalist
society would not occur as Marx had
predicted for Marx the transformational
stage was to be a dictatorship of the
proletariat a notion that Walker calls
idle history says Walker knows no such
transitions there exists solely more
primitive and more complicated forms in
the various evolutionary phases of
social progress furthermore the effort
to inflict a transformation upon a
people in the name of Marxist idealism
is for Rocker a tear
like any other in the epilogue to
Marxism and nationalism written after
World War 2 rocker notes that quote if
the Russian example taught us anything
it is only the fact that socialism
without political social and spiritual
freedom is inconceivable and must lead
to unlimited despotism uninfluenced in
its callousness by any ethical
restraints this was clearly recognized
by Putin when almost a hundred years ago
he said that an alliance of socialism
with absolutism would produce the worst
tyranny of all times wait a prediction
so this I think leads us to the heart of
rockers and Chomsky's work on anarchism
and to the assumptions that lie behind
it as described by for example poodle
the first step of course is to dismantle
the present state of the nation because
says Rocker
behind everything national stands the
will to power of small minorities and
the special interests of the caste and
class in the state for rocker all
nationalism quote is reactionary in
nature for it strives to enforce on the
separate parts of the great human family
a definite character according to a
preconceived idea in this respect - it
shows the interrelationship of
nationalistic ideology with the Creed of
every revealed religion says rocker
indeed says rocker national states are
political church organizations the
so-called national consciousness is not
born into man it is trained into him it
is a religious concept when as a German
a Frenchman an Italian just as one as a
Catholic a Protestant or a Jew notice
that the urgency of Rockers political
context had him writing specifically
about the natures of nationalism right
Chomsky speaks to quite a different
world when he's describes for example
the manufacture of consent since it's a
different kind of nationalism perhaps
one more strongly linked to corporatism
that is described as word nevertheless I
think that the link is there
but how without a state does one form
the kind of communities the loose
affiliations of workers and people's the
Chomsky and rocker and a few wish Harris
favor in their discussions of what a
good society should look like and on a
more emotive level what does one do what
the human beings natural and indeed
healthy attachment to home to family to
communities Rocker here makes a critical
distinction seldom discussed or even
raised in discussions of nationalism
between home and state which helps
clarify this while providing further
applicability I think to the program
that he is describing Rocker claims at
the home sentiment an attachment to that
spot of land on which a man has spent
the years of his youth is deeply into
grown with the profoundest of feelings
indeed says rocker early impressions of
home are most permanent and had the more
lasting impression on his soul they can
even bring in later years some yearning
after a past long buried under ruins and
offer the romantic the means to look so
deeply within so this vision that rocker
is describing is therefore not to be
confused with the kind of flag waving or
sentimentality invoking
that the state undertakes in an effort
to get them and get people attached to
the state as opposed to the home indeed
says rocker the attempt to replace man's
natural attachment to the home by a
dutiful love of the state a structure
which owes its creation to all sorts of
actions and within which with brutal
force elements have been welded together
that have no necessary connection is
perhaps one of the most grotesque
phenomena of our time this state
fanaticism which has come to replace in
Rockers view religious fanaticism has
become according to rocker the greatest
obstacle to cultural development now the
kind of cultural development to which
rocker refers in this assertion includes
I think creative production in the
broadest sense an upshot of unfetter in
human beings is that their creative
abilities thereby are allowed to
flourish
under state-directed oppression human
relationships are according to rocker
perverted says rocker the shocking
inequality of human conditions and above
all the state which bred the monopolies
who is festering cancerous growth has
destroyed the fine tissue of social
relationships this attempt to describe
human relationships as kind of organic
falls into line I think with Chomsky
sense of how of the preciousness of
human community in relationships and how
one must act to promote these
relationships the anarchist society
hereby imagined would allow all persons
to explore the innate qualities with
which each is endowed the innate
qualities that are also and this is an
interesting link to linguistics to
search the object of his search
as regards linguistics for someone
interested in this kind of discussion of
anarchism one of the clearest
descriptions that the anarchist society
as described by rocker and by Chomsky is
to be found in a short book called
anarchism and anarcho-syndicalism here
in rocker advocates quote the abolition
of economic monopolies and of all
political and social coercive
institutions within society in their
place rocker suggests that there should
exist a free association of all
productive forces based upon cooperative
labor which would have for its sole
purpose the satisfying of the necessary
requirements of every member of society
with his hatred of nationalism one can
imagine as well that rocker would
propose a replacement for the state
apparatus and indeed he suggests that
quote in place of the present national
states with their lifeless machinery of
political and bureaucratic institutions
anarchists desire a federation of free
communities which will be bound to one
another by their common economic and
social interests and arranged their
affairs by mutual agreement and free
contract ok Chomsky's own words indicate
the relationship between his own
approach and the one advocated in this
very text by Rudolf rocker in the recent
book powers and prospects Chomsky writes
that quote my personal
visions are fairly traditional anarchist
ones with origins in the Enlightenment
and classical liberalism of the type
that I described earlier on this version
of classical liberalism is what Chomsky
calls quote the original before it was
broken on the rocks of rising industrial
capitalism as Rudolf rocker put in his
work on Anarchy anarcho-syndicalism 60
years ago broken and perhaps as well
forgotten so the final question I'd like
to address then is if as I am suggesting
rocker and Harris are critical for an
understanding both of Chomsky's own work
but also of what one can do in society
even now how does one gain access to
this material where does one learn about
it and so forth this is no small matter
since this is far from being mainstream
kind of work one of the things one of
the tools that has been set up in
association with this book is a website
MIT press digital lab set up a website
which allows you not only to read the
entire text of the book on the web but
also allows you when you come across
something is unfamiliar to you like for
example if it were rocker or Paul
mattock or council communism or
something allows you to click on that
area and you will be sent off to a site
which describes how exactly this this
whole world would work this is a very I
think an interesting use of the web so
as I said as I said the entire book is
present and various areas that I had
imagined would be relatively unknown to
people are then hooked in thanks to the
thanks to the net furthermore we've set
up an interactive laboratory which
allows people through the genius of the
of the press to come through and discuss
issues such as well how does Anna Howard
honor Konerko syndicalism work today and
what are we what is the relationship
between left scientism which you
described heavily and contemporary
problems in Israel those kinds of
questions are raised in the laboratory
and finally there's another section
which discusses specifically the work of
zelich Harris
and its relationship to Noam Chomsky and
also is its own context and world
something that I'm working on for future
research so just as a just to name it
it's WWE MIT press point MIT point edu
slash Chomsky so this is the beginning
of an answer to the question how do we
gain access to the work that could be
deemed to be extremely important for an
understanding of Chomsky's work and also
for an understanding of contemporary
society I'd be happy to entertain
questions sure ww mit press point MIT
point edu slash Chomsky and this was Ben
Williams and Marnie Smith in the digital
lab and so forth who are regulating this
will and set it up you can either make
comments to them or else directly to me
via the via the site
so I'd be happy to entertain questions
so this ends robert's formal
presentation again we'd like to thank
him for coming and as he says now he'll
be glad to take questions for many of
you please let's proceed informally as
if just as if c-span we're not here I'd
like to remind you that we have free
coffee and cookies here
yes presentation but speaking of the lip
have you had any chance to use online
archive like spunk press are you
familiar with that the some of the
online archives have been linked up to
this site if there are others that are
not there we certainly like to know
about the knife certainly used some of
them yes okay bring with it and some
online interview start putting all the
classics online Stanek well then we've
in the essays and everything
international ok well if it's not
already hooked up we we certainly thank
you ok yes left scientism and in current
developments in Israel on the website
could you to say a couple words about
that sure it was a I think that the
experience of writing the whole book was
of experience of discovering many
materials that have not been spoken of
in kind of mainstream mill years or even
or in university or anything else and I
think that the lab Zionism was of
particular interest in concern for a
number of reasons first of all to
understand the context out of which
Chomsky is coming that is he comes out
about you know his childhood and so
forth is comes out of a left scientist
background secondly to try and situate
the attacks that have been made upon
Chomsky by contemporary Zionists and to
try and understand what their
relationship is two previous
manifestations of Zionism so that was a
second reason for its interest the third
reason is that I think that a lot of
what was being talked about by for
example this Alec Harris in his work for
a VUCA and lab Zionists remains
interesting even in the present context
as certainly as soon as Israel became a
religious state the basic precepts for
the kinds of lab scientists that I'm
describing were undercut what they were
interested in was a
the base the basis of the state was to
be socialist and and not religious so
but but on the other hand I think that
by looking back to the documents and by
looking back to what it is that was
envisioned for then Palestine what was
interesting I think was that what was
proposed was that the Arabs and the Jews
had equally suffered under various forms
of oppression and therefore it would
have been logical for them to unite and
work together not against each other but
against various forces of imperialist or
religious oppression so and so I think
that even though it doesn't speak
specifically to today's Israeli context
it does speak to an interesting way of
rethinking this whole problem
yeah perhaps through revealing my own
ignorance of anarchist theory but in in
Chomsky's work or rudolf rockers or
anybody else's what what is the
democratic means by which the kind of
society they envision can be achieved
and and by which illegitimate force and
hierarchy can be contained or avoided
hmm the I mean there are a few points
that are raised in the discussion of the
transformation towards anarchist society
one of which is that the process the
so-called process is when described by
Chomsky generally a kind of spontaneous
uprising there's no sense that there
should be a vanguard that would direct
and say this this is the way that the
anarchist society should look in his
sense and I think that this is also in
rocker there is a kind of logic and and
rationality and sends behind the kind
this kind of society whereby people come
together and form associations around
common themes or projects or concerns so
what I find intriguing about that is
that there is the sense that we we as a
group now I have a common purpose
through the production of something or
the you know the pursuing of a certain
cultural question or something and that
this can be undertaken informally
without either a profit profit motive or
without some other motive coming in the
way so that the free association would
occur the product that you were working
to develop or something could be
developed with without in a sense in an
unfettered way in a way unfettered by
for example the constraints of
profit-making and then once this was
completed if it was deemed appropriate
that the association dissolved it would
simply dissolve so that I think the
whole notion of democracy and so forth
its if that would have to be worked out
according to the different associations
and according to what it is that people
were working on but there's there's no I
don't think there's any any Bible that
one would read to see it
perhaps unrealistic view of human nature
look this is the most frequently
expressed I think problem with with the
anarcho-syndicalism anarchism even you
know anti-bolshevik Marxist models as I
pointed out in here one of the notions
is taken for granted in rocker and that
was why that passage is sort of
interesting in his work is that when
people are freed of oppressive forces
and are not forced by the profit motive
and so forth the whole attitudes towards
one another and so where there's
necessarily going to change and that's
one point the second point is and I
think that Chomsky shares this quite
strongly is that human nature is not I
don't think in their sense defined by
its maliciousness or desire to tyrannize
or something but more by a incredible
creative ability and so forth and since
in the world that they describe which
has in in some manifestations existed
for example in Spain and 30s you have
the the possibility of not not just
living a life that's far more enriched
and so forth but also of moving forward
and in all sorts of areas be they
industrial or cultural or whatever else
we get this implement this all over the
world at the same time I mean for
instance China with a billion people
there on educate many of them uneducated
I don't know how this would be possible
to implement at the same time you're you
mean that as a the problems that these
kinds of communities would pose in
Western civilization versus in other
areas such as China that is that there
would be different problems posed in
different countries in areas
No
I don't know I think that one of
Chomsky's own points is that the system
as it exists now requires such a massive
if you wish policing and such a massive
intervention on the part of a small
elite to maintain their power that we
are perhaps given the very illusory
sense that this system is in somehow
working in and then somehow accords with
basic needs or something but you know
and the massive studies that he does
indicates everything that you know
quite the contrary in fact so that's
that's one point I think to be said the
other point is of course in various
areas of the world the problems that are
that are to be faced and the kinds of
free associations that would need to be
set up and elaborated and so forth would
vary and the and the obstacles that they
would face and so forth would vary from
time to time and from place to place I
don't think that there's a kind of again
to in response to your question I don't
think that there's a kind of global
vision of this is the this is the
appropriate way for a free association
to look if that is going to take its own
course based upon the interests of
indigenous groups and and and social
groups and various sorts at various
times the model of the association and
spontaneous democracy did you were
talking about Chomsky talks about it
seems to be in contradiction it's like
contradiction with the global forces of
globalization global media the u.s.
foreign policy other issues that he also
talks about that are really beyond the
the power of local communities to to to
combat how do you reconcile that that's
it I mean that's a I think a critical
point as well because it speaks not not
so much to the
- the way that the society will look
subsequent to transformation if this
were to occur but the obstacle is that
those who are interested in the
transformation of society towards far
more equal or far more open and free
society are going to face the interests
of these so-called world economy with
these so-called world organizations and
so forth are obviously going to put be
put into massive question by such
movements and therefore I think that
what you're speaking to is very much the
problem of the transformation towards
something freer in this sense I find
Harris's book fascinating to tell you
the truth because which what what he is
suggesting in the transformation of
capitalist society is that this movement
will occur within the the present day
capitalism and that the contradictions
of capitalism and the cyclical downturns
of capitalism and the areas of
unprofitability that exist presently in
capitalism for example open up the
spaces for the possibility of the
elaboration of small groups of this of
this sort now what the Harris I think
assumes is that once this occurs workers
will be unwilling to go back into the
normal corporatist work for a work world
and will recognize the advantages of
this kind of system again as I mentioned
Chomsky I think is it somewhat that's
certainly it's going to occur in this in
this way but what I would I again what I
think is compelling about Harris's work
is if it does at least give you some
sense of how you're going to move
towards another form of ownership of
property at least and then globalization
or whatever one would call it the
ability to transmit information and use
products from various parts of the world
that could only be advantageous to a
world of free association there could
only be a good thing the problem is
getting there
yes may I please ask you to elaborate on
the view of human nature presupposed by
Chomsky's linguistics and the view of
human nature that you've just spoken
about that his theories of society are
based on here I think the you know there
there have been all sorts of discussions
about the incompatibility between the
scientific work and most more
specifically the view of human nature
proposed in the linguistic work and that
which charms to propose I don't think I
know I myself don't see such a strong
contradiction because what I think I
what one sees in for example is
contemporary work in the minimalist
program is the sense that there are
fundamental and basic and innate
qualities to human beings which
characterizes as human beings and the
compatibility between the project's the
linguistic and the political is in a
sense if you ask the question how best
allow these innate abilities which turn
out to be creative and as I said it's
really non not malicious and in the way
that they're often described how best
allow them to thrive and there you would
say well what seems most appropriate for
the human being to manifest this kind of
creative creativity is the kind of
society that he's describing so in other
words I don't think there to be a
contradiction between the two I think in
fact that one of them is a scientific
endeavor to understand what the nature
what the nature of the brain is or what
the nature of the language faculty is
what what does it look like and we're
not gonna be able to change that that's
the way it is that's the way we were
born that's why we don't have feathers
or whatever else it's fundamental and
then that's the first that's an object
of study the other object is and this is
again in perfect consistency with for
example many of the classical liberal
theorists how do we best allow those
creative
or whatever those fundamental abilities
are to flourish yes yeah I saw the
review of your book in The Washington
Post yes which as I recall basically
took you to task for not being more
critical of Chomsky yes do you have
anything a response to that yeah I
received a whole series of letters from
people based on that review people who
wrote to the person who wrote the review
and so forth and so on
one of the points that was made was that
had this been a biography of Kennedy and
had I spoken in with admiration the
review probably wouldn't have read the
same way I think that there's something
to that the second point I mean the
second way to to look at this is that I
am NOT going to pretend that that this
is a critical study but I'm also very
critical in the sense of critiquing
Chomsky because I as I ostensibly do
think that the work that he is is
undertaken is fundamental worth knowing
worth understanding and that many of
these so-called awful things that
Chomsky has been engaged in from the
voice on business and so forth which
this reviewer mentions are I think you
know unjustly and unduly discussed and
it's it's it's not so much that I'm
dismissive of the mind to discuss them
but but I don't think that they weren't
the kind of attention that his basic
project warrants so that's that would be
my he did point out that the early mill
your work is documented in there and in
in useful ways and and there I very much
agree with him so in a sense that he
thinks that I agree with Chomsky well
that's fine but he thinks that this is a
view of Chomsky that is positive well
that's true that he thinks I'm an
apologist that's wrong
I simply looked at the material and
think that in these in what is described
as being Chomsky's grateful Oz and so
bright I just don't see anything really
that substantial
truth and again if this would have been
Kennedy imagine quite differently
received
you mentioned how Chomsky has discussed
some issues that are not very hot topics
for for for research and in the links
between classical liberalism and
anarchism wasn't one I think you
mentioned yes
has there been is there Chomsky school
it are there any other and beside
yourself are there any other research
isn't in the field of political science
or philosophy or or a political economy
that have followed in his footsteps and
and and and chosen to research the
topics that he has introduced or or
highlighted one of the pleasures I think
of reading Chomsky is the wealth of
footnotes and and the references to all
sorts of names which you go to the books
when you find out that's been out of
print for 25 years and you have to chase
it down in a lot of cases these books
turn out to do the kind of research that
the Chomsky is is suggesting as regards
so I think that one of the best sources
of this kind of historical knowledge is
Chomsky himself whether it be on the
Spanish Civil where war whether it be on
Middle East or whether it be on
contemporary American politics there's a
wealth of information every one of
Chomsky's books it's a pleasure to read
it in that sense in the early mill years
that I described Seymour Melman and
those people who were around as L like
Harris I think of Melman as being a
particularly interesting example there
is also that I think tendency and then
in the people who are discussing Chomsky
that is in the people who can enlighten
us about where the interesting
references are certainly what Carlo what
a tarot has been doing over these years
is I think remarkably useful and
interesting there are many more
well allow me to thank you and if you
are at all intrigued by the Harris mill
years of the early male years or
anything of that nature knowledgeable of
and would like to know more about all of
these things are something that it's
ongoing in my own work and I'd be happy
to to engage in further discussion so
thank you very very much for coming